wird bedeutet für mich einen ort des
zusammenkommens der begegnung der
kameradschaft der begegnung mit anderen
begegnung mit sich selbst und durch
maria und durch die geschichte von
bernadette begegnen mit gott
ich habe hier soldatinnen und soldaten
erlebt die wirklich berührt waren von
dem was hier gefeiert wird und ich hoffe
dass sie das in ihren alltag ihren
dienst und ihre selbstverständnis als
soldatinnen und soldaten mitnehmen
[Musik]
es ist manchmal ein wenig mühselig aber
das gehört zu den bilder fahrten mehr
dazu man wird aus irgendeinem alltags
getriebe herausgerissen und denkt sich
ich hab so viel zu tun und die war schon
so oft dort aber es täte mir jedes mal
wenn ich nicht dabei gewesen wäre
und auch heuer
[Musik]